THIS YOU READY FOR OUR
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> LET’S HIT IT.
♫
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, IN THE
WAKE OF THIS TRAGIC SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN FLORIDA,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SHOWING
SOME VERY STRONG LEADERSHIP.
IS HE NOW TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO KEEP AMERICA’S
SCHOOLS SAFE, OUR KIDS SAFE.
ENDURING ANOTHER WHITE HOUSE
LISTENING SESSION TODAY HE
OFFERED UP IDEAS AND
SOLUTIONS.
LET’S TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT
HE HAD TO SAY.
>> WE HAVE TO HARDEN OUR
SCHOOLS, NOT SOFTEN THEM UP.
A GUN-FREE ZONE TO A KILLER
OR SOMEBODY THAT WANTS TO BE
A KILLER, THAT’S LIKE GOING
IN FOR THE ICE CREAM.
THAT’S LIKE HERE I AM, TAKE
ME.
WE HAVE TO GET SMART ON
GUN-FREE ZONES.
WHEN THEY SAY IT SAYS THIS
IS A GUN-FREE ZONE, THAT
MEANS NOBODY HAS A GUN
EXCEPT THEM.
NOBODY IS GOING TO BE
SHOOTING BULLETS IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION.
THEY SEE THAT AS SUCH A
BEAUTIFUL TARGET.
THEY LIVE FOR GUN-FREE
ZONES.
I THINK A CONCEALED PERMIT
FOR HAVING TEACHERS AND
LETTING PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE
BUILDING WITH GUN, YOU WON’T
HAVE, IN MY OPINION, YOU
WON’T HAVE THESE SHOOTINGS,
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE
COWARDS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO WALK
INTO A SCHOOL IF 20% OF THE
TEACHERS HAVE GUNS.
IT MAY BE 10% OR MAY BE 40%.
WHAT I WOULD RECOMMEND DOING
IS THE PEOPLE THAT DO CARRY,
WE GIVE THEM A BONUS.
WE GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT OF
A BONUS, BUT THE NRA IS
READY TO DO THINGS PEOPLE
LIKE TO BLAME THEM AND THEY
DO HAVE POWER AND ALL OF
THAT.
BUT THEY WANT TO DO -- THEY
ACTUALLY CAME UP WITH
CERTAIN OF THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE
NOW.
BUT WE’RE GOING TO HAVE TO
TOUGHEN -- I TOLD THEM WE
HAVE TO TOUGHEN THEM UP.
WE REALLY DO HAVE TO HAVE
OFFENSIVE MEASURES, ALSO.
I KNOW PEOPLE DON’T LIKE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
BUT WE NEED OFFENSIVE AS
WELL AS DEFENSIVE.
WE HAVE TO BE TOTALLY DEVIN.
IF WE DON’T HAVE OFFENSIVE
MEASURES, WITHIN THESE
SCHOOLS, WE ARE JUST -- YOU
ARE JUST KIDDING YOURSELVES,
FOLKS.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, YOU HAVE
TO GIVE THE PRESIDENT A LOT
OF CREDIT BECAUSE INSTEAD OF
ENGAGING IN THE SAME OLD
TIRED BACK AND FORTH,
REPEATING THE SAME TALKING
POINTS, THE POLITICIANS, THE
MEDIA USE AFTER THESE
TRYING TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS, SOLVING THE
PROBLEM.
NOW, HERE’S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WE HAVE A CHOICE IN ALL OF
THIS.
DO WE KEEP HAVING THE EXACT
SAME POLITICAL DEBATE THAT
WE HAVE HAD ONGOING SINCE
COLUMBINE THAT’S NOT GOING
TO CHANGE ANYBODY’S MINDS OR
DO WE ACTUALLY FIX THE
PROBLEM?
DO WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN?
NOW, REMEMBER, AFTER 9/11,
WELL, WE FIXED THE PROBLEM
OF AIRCRAFT SECURITY AND I
AM A VERY STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
I’M SURE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
ARE AS WELL TONIGHT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
PREDICTABLY THE LEFT AND THE
LIBERAL MEDIA THAT ARE
TALKING ABOUT GETTING RID OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT, ARE
TALKING ABOUT CONFISCATING
GUNS LIKE AUSTRALIA FOR A
MINUTE, LET’S TAKE POLITICS
OUT OF ALL OF THIS.
LET’S JUST FOCUS ON THE
ISSUE HOW DO WE KEEP OUR
KIDS SAFE IN SCHOOL IN THE
PRESIDENT SAYING HE WANTS
SOLUTIONS AND THAT’S WHY HE
SAT DOWN WITH STUDENTS AND
PARENTS AND TEACHERS AND
GOVERNORS AND STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS.
NOW, HE TALKED AND HE
LISTENED.
AND BY THE WAY HE WANTS TO
HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT.
THIS IS A SIMPLE TRUTH.
THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA CAN
TALK ALL THEY WANT ABOUT
BANNING CERTAIN TYPES OF
WEAPONS USED BY THESE EVIL
MANIACS.
BUT THE THING IS YOU COULD
NEVER STOP THE EVIL THAT
EXIST IN SOME PEOPLE’S
HEARTS.
AND IF YOU TAKE AWAY AND YOU
BAN ONE WEAPON, THESE
KILLERS, THOSE WITH EVIL
INTENT WILL USE SOMETHING
ELSE.
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN THIS
HAPPEN.
LET’S GO BACK TO THE
VIRGINIA TECH SHOOTING, THE
DEADLIEST SHOOTING IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY AND
IN THAT CASE THE SHOOTER
USED PISTOLS.
AND WHAT THE LEFT, THE MEDIA
CANNOT SEEM TO COMPREHEND OR
DON’T WANT TO COMPREHEND IS
THAT EVIL EXISTS IN THIS
WORLD THERE ARE MURDERERS,
THERE ARE RAPISTS.
CHILD MOLESTERS, THERE IS
EVIL.
IF THEY DON’T USE A RIFLE IN
THE CASE OF THESE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS THEN IT’S GOING TO
END UP BEING A HANDGUN THE
NEXT TIME.
AFTER THAT IF IT’S NOT A
HANDGUN IT’S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER TYPE OF WEAPON OR
TOOL.
REMEMBER THE BOSTON BOMBERS
THEY USED EXPLOSIVES THAT
WERE MADE FROM EVERY DAY
PRODUCTS THAT ARE READILY
AVAILABLE.
OTHER TERRORISTS HAVE USED
TRUCKS, VANS, AND CARS.
OTHERS HAVE USED KNIVES.
ARE WE GOING TO BAN
EVERYTHING?
AS MUCH AS THE LEFT AND THE
MEDIA WANT TO THINK THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CAN FULLY STOP
THESE KILLERS WITH
REGULATIONS AND LAWS, THEY
CANNOT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
THIS EVIL, THEY WILL ALWAYS
FIND A WAY TO CAUSE PAIN AND
SUFFERING AND INFLICT
MAXIMUM CARNAGE.
THE ONLY THING THAT COMES
WITH BANNING WEAPONS IS THAT
YOU WILL INFRINGE ON THE
RIGHTS OF CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
ABIDING AMERICAN CITIZENS
THAT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WHAT’S MISSING ARE REAL
SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT THESE
INNOCENT KIDS.
THEY BROUGHT UP A LOT OF
GREAT IDEAS AND SOLUTIONS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
ON THIS SHOW.
IN THE CASE OF THE FLORIDA
SCHOOL SHOOTING.
THERE WERE WARNING SIGNS ALL
OVER THE PLACE ABOUT NIKOLAS
CRUZ.
WE KNEW THAT HE WAS MENTALLY
ILL.
WE KNEW HE WAS UNSTABLE.
WE KNEW HE WAS CAPABLE OF
DOING SOMETHING.
OF THE STUDENTS ALL SEEMED
TO KNOW IT AND THE SAME GOES
FOR THE TEACHERS.
THERE ARE REPORTS THAT
POLICE WERE ACTUALLY CALLED
TO CRUISE’S HOME 3 TIMES
OVER A 7-YEAR PERIOD.
THAT’S A PRETTY GOOD
INDICATOR.
CRUZ GOT INTO TROUBLE AT
SCHOOL.
HE THREATENED STUDENTS.
HE WASN’T ALLOWED TO CARRY A
BACKPACK AT THE SCHOOL.
AND HE WAS EVENTUALLY
EXPELLED FROM THE SCHOOL.
THE MIAMI HERALD REPORTS
THAT SCHOOL OFFICIALS
ACTUALLY SENT OUT AN EMAIL
WARNING TEACHERS ABOUT
NIKOLAS CRUZ.
AND THEN E OF COURSE, HAVE
YOU HIS SOCIAL MEDIA
FOOTPRINT.
HAD YOU PICTURES WITH GUNS
AND KNIVES AND DISTURBING
PHOTOS.
THEN OF COURSE THE FBI THEY
WERE CALLED AND WARNED THEY
DID NOT FOLLOW UP.
IN OTHER WORDS, EVERY BIT OF
EVIDENCE TO INDICATE THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN WAS
RIGHT THERE IN FRONT OF US.
PEOPLE SAW SOMETHING, SAID
SOMETHING, AND NOTHING
HAPPENED LEARNING TWO MORE
PIECES OF INFORMATION
TONIGHT.
SECURITY CAMERAS WERE ON A
NEARLY HALF HOUR DELAY WHICH
SLOWED DOWN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THEIR ABILITY TO CAPTURE
NIKOLAS CRUZ BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF SAYING THE ARMED
SECURITY OFFICER ON CAMPUS
DIDN’T ENTER THE BUILDING
WHEN THE SHOOTING WAS TAKING
PLACE.
INSTEAD THE OFFICER TOOK A
DEFENSIVE POSITION OUTSIDE
OF THE SCHOOL.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED
SOLUTIONS.
WE NEEDEDIES.
WE NEED TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR KIDS.
HERE’S THE THING.
WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT WORKS.
AND THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE
USE EVERY DAY IN OFFICE
BUILDINGS AND AIRPORTS AND
COURTHOUSES AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS AND
OTHER FACILITIES.
THE KEY IF YOU WANT TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM IS SECURITY AND
IT’S NOT REALLY THAT HARD
THREAT ASSESSMENT CAN BE
DONE BY RETIRED OR FORMER
POLICE OR RETIRED FORMER
MILITARY, SPECIAL OPS, THESE
SCHOOLS ARE SOFT TARGETS
[APPLAUSE]
>> WE NEED TO HARDEN THE
PERIMETERS AROUND THESE
SCHOOLS.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WORRIED
ABOUT THE COST, REALLY?
ARE WE GOING TO BE CHEAP
WHEN IT COMES TO DEFENDING
OUR KIDS?
I ALSO GUARANTEE YOU THESE
FORMER OFFICERS AND
VETERANS, THEY WOULD LINE UP
AND VOLUNTEER TO HELP THEIR
COMMUNITY TO KEEP OUR KIDS
SAFE.
[APPLAUSE]
THESE NEED TO INCLUDE WAYS
TO SECURE THE PERIMETER AND
EVERY POINT OF ENTRY.
FROM THERE, IF THESE EXPERTS
DETERMINE THAT IT’S NEEDED,
YOU ARE NEED TO PUT AN ID
SYSTEM IN PLACE.
ZERO EXCEPTIONS.
THEY NEED TO KNOW EVERYBODY
THAT GOES INTO THAT SCHOOL.
I WORK IN TWO OFFICE
BUILDINGS IN NEW YORK.
ONE FOR RADIO, ONE FOR TV.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE A WORK
I.D.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED ENTRY.
VISITORS ARE VETTED THROUGH
A SECURITY SYSTEM.
AND YOU MUST SHOW YOUR I.D.
AND THEN YOU USUALLY CHECKED
IN CASE YOU HAVE ANY METAL
OBJECTS GOING.
IN AND FROM THERE ON A
CASE-BY-CASE BASIS IF
SCHOOLS NEED IT THEY SHOULD
HAVE METAL DETECTORS AND
OTHER SECURITY MEASURES.
FINALLY YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
ARMED SECURITY PRESENT AT
EVERY SCHOOL IN AMERICA
[APPLAUSE]
>> AND YOU CAN HIRE RETIRED
VETERANS AND POLICE
OFFICERS.
SCHOOLS CAN NO LONGER BE
SOFT TARGETS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE
THERE WHO CAN FIGHT BACK AND
CHALLENGE AND CONFRONT ANY
POTENTIAL THREAT.
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
STATISTIC BROUGHT UP AT THE
WHITE HOUSE LISTENING
SESSION YESTERDAY, THE
AVERAGE SCHOOL SHOOTING
LASTS ONLY THREE MINUTES.
IT TAKES POLICE ON AVERAGE 6
TO 8 MINUTES TO RESPOND,
WHICH, BY THE WAY IS
INCREDIBLY FAST.
WHY NOT ALREADY HAVE
SOMEBODY ON THE SCENE THAT
IS ARMED, THAT IS TRAINED
AND READY TO RESPOND AND
SAVE LIVES AT A MOMENT’S
NOTICE?
[APPLAUSE]
WE TAKE SECURITY THREATS
AGAINST.
LOOK AT OSCARS PREMADONNA
CELEBRITIES.
WHY WOULDN’T WE DO THE SAME
THING FOR OUR CHILDREN?
AND, IN ADDITION, TO ALL OF
THAT, WE ALSO NEED A MUCH
BETTER WAY TO HELP THESE
KIDS OBVIOUSLY IN TROUBLE.
THERE HAS TO BE A SYSTEM PUT
IN PLACE TO SPOT KIDS THAT
WE THINK ARE DISTURBED.
WE NEED TO HELP THEM, GET
THEM THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED.
AND WE HAVE TO PUT A FOCUS
ON SOCIAL MEDIA WHETHER IT’S
SOMEONE PHYSICALLY
MONITORING IT OR EASIER,
SOMEBODY REPORTS WHAT’S
GOING ON NUT CASE OF THIS
DICK KID NIKOLAS CRUZ.
NOW, ALSO ON THIS STAGE
EARLIER TODAY, THE NRA CEO
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
WAYNE LAPIERRE.
HE WAS HERE AT CPAC.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HE DELIVERED A FIERY
RESPONSE TO LIBERALS IN THE
MEDIA THAT ARE TRYING TO
BLAME HIS ORGANIZATION FOR
WHAT HAPPENED IN FLORIDA.
LAPIERRE ALSO CHALLENGED
THEM TO DO MORE TO PROTECT
SCHOOLS AND TO PROTECT OUR
KIDS.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> CHRIS MURPHY, NANCY
PELOSI, AND MORE, CHEERED ON
BY THE NATIONAL MEDIA, EAGER
TO BLAME THE NRA AND CALL
FOR EVEN MORE GOVERNMENT
CONTROL.
THEY HATE THE NRA.
THEY HATE THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
THEY HATE INDIVIDUAL
FREEDOM.
IN THE RUSH OF CALLS FOR
MORE GOVERNMENT, THEY HAVE
ALSO REVEALED THEIR
TRUESELVES.
THE ELITES DON’T CARE NOT
ONE WIT ABOUT AMERICA’S
SCHOOL SYSTEM AND SCHOOL
CHILDREN.
IT’S A BIZARRE FACT THAT IN
THIS COUNTRY OUR JEWELRY
STORES, ALL OVER THIS
COUNTRY ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THAN OUR CHILDREN.
OUR BANKS, OUR AIRPORTS, OUR
NBA GAMES, OUR NFL GAMES,
OUR OFFICE BUILDINGS, OUR
MOVIE STARS, OUR
POLITICIANS, THEY ARE AWFUL
MORE PROTECTED THAN OUR
CHILDREN AT SCHOOL.
DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE TO
ANYBODY?
>> Sean: NOW WAYNE LAPIERRE,
RIGHT?
GOOD POINTS.
HE ALSO POINTED OUT HOW THE
NRA HAS LED THE EFFORT TO
KEEP THE GUNS OUT OF HANDS
OF CRIMINALS AND FROM PEOPLE
THAT SHOULDN’T HAVE THESE
WEAPONS.
OF COURSE, IF YOU ARE
WATCHING THE CORRUPT MEDIA
IN THIS COUNTRY LISTENING TO
TO DEMOCRATS IN WASHINGTON.
THEY WILL NEVER TELL YOU
THAT BECAUSE WE ARE ONLY
INTERESTED IN DEMONIZING THE
SECOND AMENDMENT SUPPORTERS
IT’S ALL PREDICTABLE AND
PATHETIC.
FOR EXAMPLE, ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS LOOK AT WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED DURING CNN’S FAKE
NEWS TOWN HALL LAST NIGHT.
FAX DIFFERING OPINION DIDN’T
MATTER.
CNN STACKED THE DECK AGAINST
SECOND AMENDMENT SUPPORTERS.
JUST TAKE A LOOK DANA LOESCH
WILL JOIN US IN A MINUTE AT
HOW SHE WAS TREATED LAST
NIGHT.
>> LET ME ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
CAN YOU SHOUT ME DOWN WHEN
I’M FINISHED BUT LET ME
ANSWER EMMA’S QUESTION.
THEY SPOKE BEFORE B. THAT
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT MADE A
MOVE AND THEY SPOKE ABOUT
THAT BEFORE ATTORNEY GENERAL
JEFF SESSIONS’ MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT TOO.
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION
TO THAT.
>> AND I UNDERSTAND YOU ARE
STANDS UP FOR THE NRA AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT’S WHAT YOU
ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
JEW U.S. TOLD THIS GIEWP
PEOPLE PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE
STANDING UP FOR THEM.
YOU ARE NOT STANDING UP FOR
THEM UNTIL YOU SAY I WANT
LESS WEAPONS.
>> WE HAD THREE LAWMAKERS ON
THIS STAGE AND ONLY ONE OF
THEM HINTED AT REINFORCING
THE BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM.
IT IS ONLY AS GOOD AS THE
RECORD SUBMIT YOU HAD TO IT
ONLY ONE OF THEM EVEN GOT
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO MENTIONING
THAT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE MORE THAN 38
STATES SUBMIT RECORDS.
THAT’S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO.
[YOU’RE A MURDERER.
>> WE HAVE TO DEVELOP BETTER
PROTOCOL TO FOLLOW UP ON RED
FLAGS.
>> Sean: DANA WILL BE HERE
IN A SECOND.
YOU HEARD PEOPLE SAYING BURN
HER.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
HOW CAN ANYBODY HAVE A
SERIOUS CONVERSATION WHEN
ONE SIDE IS CALLING THE
OTHER SIDE MURDERERS AND
SCREAMING THAT THEY NEED TO
BE BURNED.
235EUBG MUST, CNN, THEY ARE
NOT INTERESTED IN SOLUTIONS.
THIS WAS ALL ABOUT POLITICAL
THEATER.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, IT DID
NOTHING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
FAKE NEWS CNN ALSO HAS
ANOTHER SERIOUS PROBLEM ON
THEIR HANDLED.
A STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT.
HE ACTUALLY SAVED LIVES
DURING THE SHOOTING.
AND IS HE REPORTING THAT CNN
ACTUALLY TRIED TO SCRIPT HIS
QUESTIONS AT LAST NIGHT’S
TOWN HALL THAT HE DIDN’T END
UP PARTICIPATING IN BECAUSE
HE WASN’T GOING TO BE A PART
OF THAT FARCE.
HERE IS WHAT THAT STUDENT
TOLD OUR OWN TUCKER CARLSON
EARLIER TONIGHT.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I HAVE THIS STRAIT SO
YOU SENT THEM A LONG IN
EFFECT ESSAY ON WHAT YOU
THOUGHT BUT THEY PUT THEIR
OWN WORDS IN THE QUESTION
AND THEY WEREN’T THE NAMES
YOU HAD SENT IN.
THEY WERE THE PRODUCER’S
WORDS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY HAD TAKEN WHAT I HAD
WROTE AND WHAT HI BRIEFED ON
AND TAWNGSD ABOUT, THEY
ACTUALLY WROTE THE QUESTION
FOR ME.
>> Tucker: BUT NOT WITH YOUR
WORDS.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ASKED TO
YOU SEND QUESTIONS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: THAT SEEMS
DISHONEST.
>> IT DEFINITELY DID.
AND THAT’S KIND OF WHY I
DIDN’T GO LAST NIGHT.
ORIGINALLY I HAD THOUGHT
THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE MORE
OF MY OWN QUESTION AND MY
OWN SAY AND THEN IT TURNED
OUT TO BE MORE OF JUST THE
SCRIPT.
AND SHE HAD ACTUALLY SAID
THAT OVER THE PHONE THAT I
NEEDED TO STICK WITH THE
SCRIPT.
>> Sean: SO THE STUDENTS
SAYING.
[CROWD BOOING]
FAKE NEWS SCRIPTED HIS
QUESTIONS.
AND WHAT DID YOU THEM?
>> FAKE NEWS.
>> Sean: OH E OKAY.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY WOULD
NEVER PROVIDE SCRIPTED
QUESTIONS AND COLTON’S
FATHER WITHDREW HIS NAME
FROM PARTICIPATING BEFORE
THE SHOW BEGAN.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THAT THE FAKE NEWS NETWORK
HAS BEEN ACCUSE OF SCRIPTING
QUESTIONS.
MICHELLE MALKIN PUT OUT A
GREAT ARTICLE IN 2016 FOR
"THE NEW YORK POST."
CNN’S LONG HISTORY OF
ALLOWING DEMOCRATIC TOWN
HALL PLANTS AND HERE ARE
JUST A COUPLE OF THE MANY
EXAMPLES SHE FOUND.
2007, CNN YOUTUBE DEBATE.
QUOTE UNDECIDE YOU HAD
VOTERS LITERALLY INCLUDED A
MEMBER OF THE LBGT AMERICANS
FOR HILLARY CLINTON STEERING
COMMITTEE.
JOHN EDWARDS SUPPORTER THAT
ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT
ABORTION.
LOG CABIN REPUBLICAN THAT
WAS REALLY BACKING BARACK
OBAMA.
A CONCERNED MOTHER THAT WAS
A UNION ACTIVIST FOR UNITED
STEEL WORKERS THAT IT
ENDORSED JOHN EDWARDS AND
FORMER INTERNAL FOR
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN
JANE HARMAN.
WE KNOW THAT THE FORMER DNC
CHAIR DONNA BRAZILE LEAKED
TOWN HALL QUESTIONS TO THE